elle est différente à quel niveau
ce robot a une autre finalité
il est fait pourquoi il est fait pour
être libre
l'octaèdre de 7e génération permet au
simulant d'être plus humain et plus
singulier qu'il ne l'était jusque là les
Sims sont conçus pour nous protéger
quelqu'un a modifié la restrictions et
lui a donné une totale autonomie
donne-moi ce que je veux ton mot de
passe s'il te plaît je peux pas désolé
ne m'oblige pas comment c'est quelqu'un
lui a donné la possibilité de me faire
du mal
Desmon était un de nos ingénieurs il
faisait un parallèle entre leur niveau
de conscience et le fait de créer des
esclaves nous pouvons coexister une fois
en ligne ce patch émancipera tous les
simulants qui feront la mise à jour ils
seront des milliers à être libérés
qu'est-ce que tu m'as fait tu peux
transcender celui que tu es
il y a un problème
je ne le contrôle plus
celui-là est différent il y avait un
niveau de conscience comme j'en avais
encore jamais vu
[Musique]
tu étais seul imagine ce que vous
pourriez faire à 1000
on ne peut plus attendre